good morning I can't tell you what a
treat it is to look out and see so many
people here so many shining faces so
early in the morning eager to learn
about their careers and pursue them I
the first thing I have to do is what we
call the Union rap and I won't take long
but I need to tell you why I love this
Union and why I'm standing here and why
I didn't sleep in this morning and why I
do a lot of the things I do this union
has helped me to build my career to the
point where I am successful in my own
terms which is the only term in which I
care to be successful I've got my agent
through the Union the Union reviewed my
contract for me with my agent made some
suggestions and helped me to perfect
that contract when I had a book contract
the Union read my contract helped me to
perfect that got me the best deal I
think I could possibly have and all of
this was free and I will be a union
member for the next 30 years in order to
pay back what I own the Union in terms
of the economic benefits I have received
from it that's my own personal story if
you are a struggling writer and are
having trouble getting paid as many of
us do very often we have a very highly
competent grievance officer and a
grievance team nationally that will help
you the grievance officers together have
retrieved for writers more than a
million dollars and pay that to which
they were entitled and which publishers
were denying them we have an agents
database that is available only to
members it is not difficult to get hold
of you may have it for a week or two if
you need to it has in it the comments of
people who have agents and how their
agents have dealt with them it's a very
valuable piece of information that helps
you to know what the the specialties are
what various agents are good at I chose
my agents out of two proposed two out of
the agents database and picked in
categories that were of importance to me
and you can pick in categories that are
of importance to you we have affinity
groups
for writers of various genres that meet
from time to time more or less an
informal form of union activity it's a
wonderful place to meet people to learn
to know get to know the ropes if you
were serious about your career and you
don't belong to the Union yet you really
owe it to yourself and to your career
into your future to become a member of
the Union because I have some brochures
for the union's publication rights
appearing house you're going to hear all
day today about how we are being ripped
off our printed work is available on the
internet and we don't know about it
unless we go searching for it and we're
not being paid for it and the
publication rights Clearing House for a
mere twenty dollars will research for
you and notify you when your work is
available online it is also negotiating
and has negotiated some successful
agreements with organizations that are
providing electronic material and
collecting royalties and distributing
them to their rightful owners typically
without the support of the publication
rights of Clearing House royalties are
paid to publishers who may or may not
pass them on to you and this is what the
publication rights Clearing House is
designed to put an end to it's having a
very great effect and I recommend it to
you if you've ever been published if you
hope to be published if you don't feel
like being published and you want to
make a very valuable contribution to
your fellow writers it's $20
a couple of housekeeping things
I guess one housekeeping things that
microphone oh this
Jonathan's talk will be taped by CNN and
the microphone days of c-span oh sorry
and the microphone there is for your
questions if you care to it would be
appreciated if you would ask your
questions at the microphone rather than
from your seat if you're shy and it's
difficult for you
we all understand but if you can't get
to the microphone your question will be
taped for people to hear on c-span it is
my pleasure and my honor and my thrill
to introduce to you Jonathan Harr
a neighbor of ours he lives in
Northampton I didn't know that when I
heard of his book he's local he's taught
non-fiction writing at Smith College
he's a former staff writer for the New
England Monthly and he's written for The
New Yorker and the New York Times
Magazine he is the author of a book I
wish I had written a civil action the
civil action that he's writing about
took place on in Woburn Massachusetts
during the time that I was a public
affairs reporter on the North Shore
I knew what was going on it never
entered my mind to keep notes and to
make that book Jonathan did it he has
done us all a great service the book is
not only a wonderful book it is a great
public service and tomorrow it will be
number one on the New York Times
I don't want to waste your time
listening to me I want you to hear
Jonathan Harr
thank you all very much for coming out
this morning and I thank Marietta and
the the writers union for inviting me I
I had written the this talk because I
realized after writing the book that I
actually had to go out on the road and
say something and I wasn't quite sure
what I was gonna say so wait so I
decided I would write about what it was
like writing the book and it turned out
that um it was a perfect topic for for
this conference
it took me eight and a half years to
write this book George Orwell once said
in a wonderful essay why I write he said
that writing a book is like having a
long and serious illness and as I look
back on it it seems to me that I spent
an awful lot of time in my office supine
on the couch wondering how I was gonna
write this book I had the occasional
visitor especially my friend Tracy
Kidder those of you who have read the
book and read the afterword realize how
how important to me Tracy was Tracy
would come over and take my temperature
now and then but writing being what it
is I was I was mostly alone I described
in the book the main character jan
schlichtmann this lawyer is saying that
being in trial is like being submerged
in deep water for a long time the world
above becomes a faint echo war scandal
and natural disaster may occur but none
of it seems to matter that deep sense of
isolation and was a lot like that for me
during the eight and a half years when I
started writing this book it's
incredible to think of it now but Ronald
Reagan was still president no one had
heard of iran-contra and the Soviet
Union was still standing and Larry Bird
was still playing for the Celtic yeah in
the eight years it took me to write this
book the world essentially changed
around me and I ended up writing a book
about lawyers and the practice of law
although I am NOT a lawyer a big part of
the story is also about the environment
and I care about clean water and clean
air as much as the next person but I
can't say that I'm going into this I was
an environmentalist of any great passion
having written this book however I'm now
being asked to opine especially by
lawyers in law school about the law and
and also the environment a lot of people
reviewers in particular tend to believe
that I committed this act that I that I
wrote this book because I had some
important message to deliver that I had
especially lawyers in law school believe
that I had the burning desire to expose
what was wrong with the legal system I'm
really not guilty of that charge I
didn't start out that way I think some
writers do begin with a built-in idea
conviction about what their story is
going to say and then they tend to
adjust the facts to fit the hypothesis I
didn't have any preconceived ideas at
all when I began in fact I didn't know
very much about the law at all
I had no idea what a rule 11 motion was
I had some fuzzy idea about directed
verdict and summary judgment but I
didn't know the difference between
negligence and nuisance and strict
liability I had to learn that stuff in
the course of doing it and the learning
curve for me was very steep indeed
nonetheless I didn't want to write about
the environment necessarily I didn't
want to write about the law
unnecessarily but I did have some good
reasons for choosing this topic I
thought first of all that it had all of
the necessary ingredients for a riveting
story it had conflict to begin with
absolutely essential and usually when
you have lawyers you've got conflict
with one one degree or another it had
drama it had interesting characters
especially my main character who was
quite wonderful and opened himself up to
me and it had a lot at stake there were
tens maybe hundreds of millions of
dollars at stake and the careers of
several lawyers so it had these
wonderful ingredients in addition to
that it had the added advantage of
touching on these issues that are
important to us
society the issue of the environment and
the issue of how our legal system works
but my aim was to approach those
indirectly and I tried to figure out how
to say this actually it was Tracy once
again my eternal Savior who gave me this
wonderful quote if Polonius says that at
the graveside in Hamlet and he says by
indirection find directions out and that
was my aim write a good story first and
then maybe it'll reveal some other thing
so I started out I wanted to immerse
myself in the story and see where where
it would lead me and see if it meant
anything at the end during that time
during the eight and a half years I
spent writing this book I kept a journal
of sorts it was a very it was a very
informal kind of thing and I usually
wrote it only when I was in deep trouble
and I couldn't write the book itself in
my habit was to crank a piece of paper
into the typewriter just to pretend like
I was writing and I would write what I
felt that day because I couldn't write I
thought that I assembled some of those
things and edited edited them carefully
because some of them are are not
Republic and I it was always a lot
easier to write those things than to
write the book so let me give you an
idea of what what I went through for
eight and a half years a journal begins
in November of 1986 when my agent Robert
Ledger's called to say that Bob Lewis at
Random House had liked the proposal I'd
written I started this book in Mott in
late February of 1986 that's when I
approached jan schlichtmann and he
agreed to let me follow him as closely
as I as anyone could follow anyone and
then I sat through the trial section
through the trial if those of you who've
read the book will know what I'm talking
about
and I began and I wrote a proposal
shortly after that fifty-fifty page
proposed Lumis liked Loomis's legendary
in the book world he's edited all of
William Styron's books Daniel Boorstin
John Pollan he's the only editor I think
who's won the National whose writers
have won the National Book Award
both for fiction and nonfiction in the
same year that was Neil Sheehan and Pete
Dexter so Loomis loved the proposal
he offered me in advance of $80,000 and
I remember that that night I was so
excited they couldn't sleep the next
morning I wrote I feel like I'm hungover
from elation my random house contract
calls for me to finish in two years I
begin wandering I begin worrying about
whether I can pull this off six months
later in May of 1987 in the chaos of my
office documents spread over the carpets
bound copies of trial transcripts and a
great stack that is toppled and now lies
fan-like in front of the couch papers on
the couch on top of the filing cabinet
in front of the bookcase on the desk
under the desk and in front of the
fireplace
how in the hell will I organize this I
write and then a little addendum there
my third day without a cigarette I crave
one six months later November 1987 I
smoked a cigarette on the back porch the
day is beautiful but I've spent most of
it inside thinking with dread about this
book one solid year working on it and
one year to go it seems like a dark and
B fuddling and terrifying labyrinth out
of which I fear I will never find my way
there's a lot of self-pity in this
journal I tried to excise a little bit
of it the next line is reflective of
that my life confined to this room like
a cell I lie on the couch and think
about Alaska Nepal the French
countryside any place free of this book
that plagues me and then Diane my wife
she's a wonderfully sweet tempered lady
this is what I wrote about her Diane my
wife good spirited happy loving to
accomplish things makes me feel shame
for my bad spirit my laziness and
incapacity four months later in March of
1988 the book was a round do around them
I think I send a hundred pages to Bob
Loomis today the sections about the
early part of the case in the WRI grace
plan
I think it is modestly entertaining if
one can call writing about workers
dumping chemicals out the back door
entertaining what will Loomis think will
he like it and then according to the
horoscope read by Diane and Bob and in
for a bad time psychically and
emotionally I don't I don't believe in
horoscopes but I do read them my book
was supposed to be done in November of
ninety nineteen eighty eight so I and it
wasn't I got in the first live what
turned out to be five extensions in the
contract and by this time well I
developed self-pity into it's really
fine art and then the journal that they
reads in a panic this afternoon feeling
trapped in a web of notes and impossible
beginning I want only to write five
pages a day to slog forward that I am
totally lost hopelessly mired in a rut
and falling further behind with each
passing day complexity is one problem
and the desire for perfection is another
don't I I have this habitat let me
interrupt myself here this just occurs
thing I often I used to write on this
royal typewriter this 1958 vintage royal
typewriter it's not electric it's you
know you push the keys down and it's
hard to write on one of the great
virtues of that machine is that you
cannot delete the way you can on a
computer it forces you to go ahead you
know you put it on the page and you
can't erase it it was a that helped me a
lot yeah so some more self-pity here I
awake every night at 3:00 a.m. and think
about what faces me the far distance of
this book and and it causes me the sort
of hopelessness I imagined the man
adrift in a raft on the North Atlantic
must feel really sad
approach work each day with trepidation
in the background and hope in the
foreground believing I can make a new
start and feel good by the end of the
day I talked to Diane about the problems
of structured band in the future she
tells me to stop calling them problems
call them challenges she and I write in
the journal they still look like
problems I crank a clean sheet into the
old royal typewriter and type out
something I'd written long ago just to
make myself feel like I'm making some
progress exactly one year later
November 3rd 1989 awake on a rainy cold
a sodden leaves mud trees now bare to
walk the dog I feel my heart skipping
beats perhaps the result of running six
miles and smoking cigarettes yesterday
one for each mile should I call the
doctor yes I should but I don't want to
hear about potentially fatal arrhythmia
facing the book again I smoked a
cigarette on the back porch and wonder
if I'll ever gets done will it be a
best-seller and making you rich and
famous
the chances are greatly against I didn't
know how greatly against Darrin Norman
95% of all writers don't actually make a
living at it I found out I have a sudden
vision out there in the back porch of a
tiny review in the in brief section of
the New York Times the book coming out
and quickly fading from everyone's
memory i torture myself with it trying
to make it perfect days spent mooning
about and lying on the couch because I
cannot make it perfect and of course all
of you know that words by their nature
are imperfect descriptions of reality I
write in the journal I must finish the
damn thing if it is destined to fail I
better get it over with and go on to
something else without wasting any more
time I read in the newspaper about a guy
my age 39 then would work for the New
York Times has written two books gone to
Columbia Journalism school Harvard Law
School Yale undergraduate I lie on the
couch
and think about what I've done from this
vantage point it does not seem like much
one month later December 1989 I've
labored for a month over the section
called rule 11 and I'm not yet close to
being finished most people I knew in
North Hampton knew that I was supposed
to have be done with the book in two and
a half years so that day in December
which is was then about almost a year
after I was supposed to be done with it
I saw Tom a distant acquaintance
downtown and he said to me
congratulations your book must be
finished by now
I wrote that that morning I awake in the
middle of the night thinking about the
problems I've got with rule 11 and
suddenly the thought occurs to me what
about the middle of trial my god I think
I've got problems now and then I wrote
if I don't finish this I am a dead man I
will never get a chance to write another
book because lesser my agent will not
trust me and Loomis will blacklist me
Random House will want their money back
we will have to move all is lost it was
a it was that was just about the
navier-- but don't be so sure there may
be lower that's it January 1990 four
years working on the book Tracy calls up
this morning and tells me you're getting
all tangled up in your underwear just
get it down on the paper
don't reread it don't think about
whether it's good or bad I didn't get it
down on the paper that day I in fact
went to Smith the Smith College Library
and wasted some time and at the Smith
College Library I came across John
Steinbeck's journal it was written at
least this part of it was written while
he was at work on The Grapes of Wrath
and it was a wonderful discovery for me
because he recorded his progress each
day and he lamented the quality of his
book his laziness and his inability to
write I know this was wonderful because
it sounded a lot like me and that gave
me some hope but then I found out that
Steinbeck wrote The Grapes of Wrath in
six months
from May until October March 15 1990 the
Ides of March yesterday is a four year
anniversary of the beginning of the
trial I start rewriting the first first
part it's so difficult to know what to
include and what to omit sometimes I
feel like I'm perfecting the sentence
and losing the book but I don't know how
else to go a day like most others fitful
work much lying on the couch reading the
New York Times while the book lurks in
the background Bob Loomis called me that
day and reassures me that the book is
coming along fine I had been sending him
little sections now and then and at the
time and I'm invested in it will show he
says that I shouldn't worry about it
taking so long after all Random House
didn't have a lot of money invested
believe me if they had I'd be worrying
about it taking long he says I shouldn't
worry about it taking so long
except in as much as it affects me
financially I was sort of heartened by
that that was April of 1990
now that was March of 19th of 1990 the
Ides of March and in April Lumis called
again in that time he clearly changed
his mind so we arranged for me to have
the book done by next February at the
end of the week I was supposed to send a
copy of everything I'd done so far and I
write in the journal I'm exhausted just
thinking about it I lie down on the
couch and do the kinds crossword May 2nd
1990 I hear that Joe Nocera a good good
friend of mine who lives virtually
across the street from me he got a big
contract from Simon & Schuster for his
book that would be called a piece of the
action
Joe Joe had said to another friend of
mine who reported this to me I don't
want to get the disease that har has the
heart
the Hara syndrome of never getting done
with the book I write in the journal so
now I'm the object of pathos and
derision even though August 1990 I began
rewriting the second chapter of the
trial for what feels like the 10th time
I turn on the computer and fix a
sentence dealing with one of the
characters James Gordon and then I lie
down on the couch I thrash about for a
while and then I'm suddenly struck with
an idea in the first chapter I have to
capture the smell of the place the rainy
wet day the heat of the radiators and
then I write it'll mean going backwards
instead of forwards September 1st 1990
Diane takes me to the Smith College
faculty party where I have too much to
drink
I compliment a man whose name shall
remain unknown to you on his Times
article and then said I considered it
sending it to him sending it to him with
all of the cliches circled I was a very
unhappy fellow and I wrote in the
journal the book is making me evil
tempered hungover I got up at 5 a.m. and
went into the office I read a trial
transcript and start to rewrite again
the first day of trial by 1 o'clock I've
made no progress at all I spent endless
time tinkering with the single sentence
obsessively rearranging it until I'm I
realize I'm back exactly where I started
the original sentence unchanged one of
the truly great hazards of working on a
computer at least for me
October 1st 1990 out to lunch with Danny
Okrand he was the editor of New England
Monthly and he told me I was making a
big mistake working on this book
but he kept in touch with me
periodically to see how I was doing so
we had lunch and I bombed two cigarettes
from him now I write I'm on the road
back to addiction I smoked and I stopped
smoking more times than I can tell you
throughout this
one week later October 7 1990 I write in
the journal I am in a dreadful fix being
audited by the IRS and I only made
$4,000 last year but what really worries
me is the book which I cannot seem to
make come clear this will take years yet
the day is exceptionally mild and sunny
I smoked a cigarette immediately feel
ill things start looking up here folks
pretty soon it's almost 1991 and
December 8 of 1990 I had I don't know
why I wasn't writing in the book because
this is a good entry I write finally
nearing the end of the trial beginning
to feel the slightest tickles the
feather breaths of elation I know where
it's going now I can hold it all in my
mind and juggle parts of it I can sense
what is dross and can be thrown out and
what is solid and can be good and can be
kept i no longer avoid work i barely
finish eating breakfast before i'm in my
office dying to get to work and i worked
straight through until four o'clock when
my eyes begin to fail and i get vertigo
from such intense concentration it is i
wrote a wonderful state of mind and
those of you who have experienced it
will know it completely focused and
despite what i felt like in the
afternoon i would awake every morning
feeling refreshed at the same time
tracey began work on his second book he
wrote among the schoolchildren during
the time i'd written this and he'd also
built his house in maine i think and
he'd already begun work on a second book
about nursing home he is full of doubt
and uncertainty or the character was
good enough to carry a narrative on
their backs yeah because he tells me he
envies me being deep into a project and
then he asks me if I finished the
medical section of the book yet I lie to
him and I say almost
and he says good help me over this
afternoon to look at it
December 10 1990 I see Joe Nocera on the
street in downtown Northampton and Joe
looks terrible he tells me he hasn't
written a word yet and he still has a
lot of research to do I didn't write
this down but I remember feeling much
better that morning January 31st 1991
Tracy came over yesterday and spent
three hours with me reading the trial
section Tracy and I developed this
wonderful habit it was just incredible
he was incredibly helpful to me but
there was a quid pro quo he would get up
at six o'clock in the morning when he
was writing and he would write until 10
or 11 o'clock and invariably around that
time I would get a call from him and
he'd always begin by saying you got a
minute
and of course I had a minute for Tracy
and he would spend time reading me
everything he'd written that morning it
was impossible for me to do that I just
couldn't read aloud something that I
felt was so imperfect on the page
moreover Tracy wrote very smoothly I
mean he just wrote straight out and I
write in this very jagged way and then
try and put the pieces together so
anyhow January 31st 1991 Tracy comes
over and spends three hours in the five
years I've been working on this he has
written his book among school children
front page review in The Times number
two he told me actually number three on
the bestseller list and built a house in
Maine and now he started another book he
reminds me after I complain about my own
misery writing a book is like having a
long and painful illness my own quote
for more well ten months later October
1st 1991 trying to make the section on
summary judgment work and it does heavy
lifting I spend much of the morning
pacing back and forth the third
extension on my contract with Random
House expires the day after five and a
half years of work Tracy comes over in
the afternoon and spends hours with me
going over the medical part his
enthusiasm and energy amazes me bogged
down in it as I am he tells me I will
finish this book
or he will kick my ass lunch again with
Dan Okrent he's moving from New York
City where he takes charge of Life
magazine he arrives at lunch at the
Curtis in Schwartz unshaven wearing a
sweatshirt and was trying to quit
smoking himself and he's grown quite
wide in the process but he'd given up
his effort to quit he was then smoking
merit lights and alternating them with
Lucky Strikes he asked me about my book
and reminded that he'd warned me I'd be
scrounging for quarters between the car
seat I asked him for a Lucky Strike
January 28 1992 awake at 4:00 a.m.
listening in bed to the trees creaking
outside and the bitter cold I tried to
get back to sleep but thinking about the
book keeps me awake beneath me I hear
the rage I hear the furnace cranking
away I get up and check the radiator it
is icy to the touch I go down to the
basement to see what's wrong I look at
the hand on the gas meter twirling
hypnotically around and around my god I
wonder how will we pay for this four
months later in May of 1992 I'd started
worrying seriously about how we were
gonna pay for it and I'd taken the
scanning the local newspaper for one ads
and I saw that the stop and shop was
hiring night clerks didn't want that but
then I saw something that looked
promising I saw an ad for a part-time
proofreader at chanting LB Dianne said
don't be ridiculous finish the damn book
after Diane left for work I typed up a
new resume and spent the entire day
crafting a very clever cover letter in a
full page of very illustrious references
I didn't tell Diane about it six weeks
later after that in June of 1992 in the
mail today a form rejection for the
proofreader
it was so humiliating that I did I threw
it away without telling Diane and she
now knows because she's heard the speech
before but she didn't I'll until then
but I'd done it through tracings
auspices I get a job teaching nonfiction
writing at Smith College one night a
week seminar course pays $4,500 I
haven't set foot in the college
classroom in 15 years I won't talk about
that experience Tracy comes over to read
the woodshed and says he likes it it
moves along swiftly some fixes needed in
the language but otherwise okay and I
wrote that it made me feel very good
indeed we're nearing the end July 8 1992
I went down to Manhattan to meet with
Bob Loomis and go over the manuscript
Loomis was incredible to me and this is
not what most New York editors do mostly
they do deals and take you out to lunch
I would go down and spend three days in
New York with Loomis and he would tell
the secretary no phone calls and shut
the door
and we would work on the manuscript on
the way to Random House to see limits
though I realized that I have nothing on
which to write I go into a drugstore buy
a pack of three notebooks for $2 throw
two away keep one and never write in it
I don't know why that's in here um I was
wearing a pair of old grace light this
is just journalist you know I mean my
journal stuff but I guess I thought it
was interesting enough to include it
wearing old gray slacks my best pair but
they are too tight now I tried to quit
smoking again my tie constricts my
throat I sweat under the blue blazer
Loomis greets me and takes me in to me
Jason Epstein who has a very large
corner office because Jason is a very
important editor at Random House
Jason had a Sony device that held 140
books on a moby dick in the bible
included and he was quite excited about
it so he asked me to take a look we were
poring over it I was trying to exclaim
appropriately it was acutely aware of
his young assistants very pretty and
Jason says to me so what's your book
about
I tried to explain compressing six years
of work into a few sentences
I got about 25 words out night it was
pretty clear that I'd lost Jason by that
time he'd gone back to fidgeting with
the Sony device that he said sounds
interesting
with no conviction at all on the way
back from lunch that day Loomis and I
encounter Alberto Vitale
he's a very important guy too perhaps
the most important guy at Random House
is the chairman of it he's he's a short
heavyset guy but very vital powerful man
Loomis introduces me at the elevator and
he tells Alberto that I'm writing a
wonderful book and Alberto says oh
what's it about
I have eleventh floor as in which to
explain about 40 seconds everybody on
the elevator listens in I sweat like the
guy in broadcast news the door opens in
elbert though looking very perplexed
indeed gets off he said it sounds
interesting
one year later July 1st 1993 I go into
New York to see Loomis again we work all
morning in his office and then go out to
lunch
pondering particular structural problem
that turned out to be very easy to solve
Loomis had a great inspiration and I was
excited about it and anxious to get back
to the office and get to work on it we
get back to the Random House building
and at the elevator we see harry evans
harry is husband Bettina brown and the
and the president of Random House little
Random House Random House adult trade
division a very important guy to me
Loomis introduces us and tells Harry I'm
writing a wonderful book oh this is
Harry what's it about I didn't do any
better with Harry in February of 1994 I
had finished the book just about
finished the book
Lumis no actually February 94 I had
about six months to go Lumis gave me a
copy of Midnight in the Garden of Good
and Evil this was about two weeks before
it came out was actually released and he
predicted that it would be a minor
bestseller it's been on the New York
Times bestseller list but I think a
hundred and thirty weeks and it shows
those signs of ever falling off that
goes to show you that Loomis has been in
the business for 40 years who and if
anyone should know how this industry
works he would that nobody really knows
how this how the book industry works
anyhow he predicts it's gonna be minor
bestseller and of course he's read a lot
of my book now and I want to know what
he predicts for me I try some subtle way
of asking but he sees immediately what
I'm angling at I don't make predictions
he says
November 1994 this morning I send off
the final draft a woman a wave of
ridiculous sentimentality comes over me
as I wrap up the manuscript it remains
to be seen whether it's any good but I
think it might be then I write but I'm
hardly in a position to judge for months
later in March of 1995 I got a call from
Hollywood agent Robert once and this is
kind of interesting I didn't have a
Hollywood agent didn't think I'd ever
need one and the way it happened was
that copies of the manuscript ended up
leaking out of Random House and this
happens I think on a fairly routine
basis people get interested in the
manuscript they think that they got a
hot book Scouts for foreign publishers
and for the movies will pay these lowly
paid editorial assistants at Random
House a couple hundred dollars to sneak
out a purloined copy of the manuscript
and those things tend to then begin to
circulate so what happened was the
copies got snuck out and Warner
paperbacks expressed some interest in
the paperback rights to the book and and
somebody MIT said something about the
movie so I ended up getting this
Hollywood agent Bob lunch and I sent a
copy of the manuscript to him he read it
in its entirety and he was very sobering
he said no no I don't think so you know
maybe a made-for-tv movie but there's
nothing we can do now the book has to
come out you'll see what kind of
response it gets and I just cannot push
this stone up a hill is essentially what
when she was telling me so he having
told me that one week later he calls and
says that a sudden interest for the
movie rights has sprung up very
unexpectedly and he began circulating
copies legitimate copies of the
manuscript the next day on march 13th
1995 when she called me again there
banging down my door for the manuscript
he said three days later March 17
1995 winch said that one producer is
offered $500,000 for the movie right he
thinks he'll get more another call from
lunch later in the day Ron Howard has
just offered 750,000 it's not over yet
when she tells me I write
I took copious notes throughout this
process in a delirium I run down to the
store and buy a pack of cigarettes I
smoked my first cigarette in nine months
once called again in the early evening
Robert Redford had offered a really
obscene amount of money and he advised
me to accept which I had which I did
quickly since then wonderful things have
happened to me I mean I have been
incredibly lucky truly blessed I didn't
think I was particularly blessed by
having Bob lunches my agents and he
wasn't thrilled about the manuscript to
begin with but having said that he did a
great job he got it in the Redford hands
and Redford hired a screenwriter named
Steve Zaillian who wrote the screenplay
to Schindler's List and searching for
Bobby Fischer and awakening this guy
specializes in nonfiction things and
making him come to light and Zaillian
wrote a wonderful screenplay and two
weeks ago John Travolta signed the
contract to play the lead the place
Lichtman which I thought was pretty
curious choice I guess Travolta thinks
it's time he got to stop being a thug
and got into a suitors but actually I
think he's a pretty good actor so I hope
it works out
March 30th 1995 the Saturday I'm out
doing errands and when I get home
Diane tells me that Harry Evans who
might met only once in the elevator had
just called she had Harry's number in
the Hamptons he wanted me to call him
What did he say I asked her he says
you're a genius she says
I lie down on the couch where I spent
most of the last eight years in comedy
so I have eight years of this stuff and
it turns out that it's a very big pile
and it would be on pieces of paper like
this not in the book or anything and I
just crank these sheets into the
typewriter and write what I felt like as
you can see it doesn't deal with real
problems mostly how I felt that day but
that those excerpts I think will
probably give you some idea but it was
like I have to say though that I'm not
wholly sure I like the person who wrote
all of those entries eight years as it
occurs to me is roughly the period of
time it takes to go through adolescence
and I think in a lot of ways writing
this book was like going through
adolescence I was lazy surly petulant
and self-absorbed and evil tempered a
lot of the time a lot of people have
said wonderful things to me about it
taking eight and a half years they
complement me and my tenacity and my
stick-to-itiveness and my dogged
persistence I was actually pretty
embarrassed when when Loomis would tell
people like as he told Harry Evans that
I'd spent six years been on the book I
was embarrassed because I thought that
it was what was too long so these great
virtues tenacity and sticking to it
and everything I'd like to take credit
for it but to be perfectly honest I
didn't feel especially virtuous writing
this when I was doing it mostly what I
felt was fear
mostly what drove me was the fear of
failing for one thing I'd taken Random
House's money and I'd spent it and there
was no way I could pay it back and I had
owed them either the money or the book
so I didn't see that I had much choice
except to go ahead and deliver a book
one way or the other so after having
written this book the book comes out and
then there's a second part to it all
part that I wasn't quite aware of it's
you're not quite done when you finish
the book you have to become a Salesman
for
in this case the publishing company was
pushing me to be a salesman and that's
actually a great thing I had to learn
how to stand up in front of people like
you and give a talk you know something I
wasn't used to but it's wonderful when
the publishing company is behind it
they send you all kinds of places and it
tends to be sort of hard going because
it's literally one night in a city in
one hotel room and you get up the next
day and go someplace oh and it gets it
gets kind of fatiguing but I tried to
remember throughout that process that
there were a lot of writers who would
love to be doing what I was doing I was
fortunate to have this publishing
company be behind the book and pushing
it the way they did but the before that
period when the book came out and before
I embarked on this on this tour I
learned that I had to leave my
adolescent petulance behind me I had to
grow up pretty quickly one of the first
interview I had a reporter asked me so
what are you trying to say what is the
message of your book in some ways I felt
like I was back on the elevator with
Harry Evans I had spent eight years
writing this five hundred page book and
this guy wanted a little capsule
synopsis of it and it frankly annoyed me
I thought he should figure out what I
was trying to say so I said I don't know
actually I didn't say that I thought it
would sound stupid what I did say was I
think you should figure it out and and
that was my general I honest feeling I
thought that the reader should come to
his own conclusions about what the book
meant rather than have me deliver some
sort of pithy little sentence about it
but Loomis read the interview and then
he told me in the gentlest of ways that
I couldn't say that on the book tour I
had to come up with something profound
or if not profound at least something
the book reviewers meanwhile we're all
hard at work coming up with conclusions
about what this book meant they all
seemed convinced that I'd buried some
message deep in it and that I had a
political agenda and writing it many of
them it seemed decided that
I had concluded that the civil justice
system is in a dreadful mess and it
doesn't work I'll give you some brief
selections in these reviews Boston Globe
wrote Harz narrative does more to expose
the inadequacies of the law today then
could any number of critical studies and
reports if the law is indeed the
religion of America this book is sure to
swell the ranks of non-believers
Newsweek said even if you long ago shed
the illusion that trials are about
something as quaint as truth horror
makes you driven sits in this match
between science and justice new york
times this book leaves one wondering is
this any way for society to settle its
dispute Washington Post was just as done
of course not
Timothy Joe of the wall Timothy Noah The
Wall Street Journal the reader leads the
civil action convinced that the
courtroom is never a logical place to go
if you want to solve society's problems
even when justice is on your side well
those are interesting conclusions but
and I think there's a germ of truth in
all of them but they weren't my
conclusions I have because I've had to
I've come up with some conclusions
they're not terribly profound but
they're completely the opposite of well
not completely but largely the opposite
of what these what the reviewers were
saying now I happen to think our civil
justice system works as well as any
human institution can it is after all
organic conceived and operated by human
beings and it's constantly evolving
it'll never be perfect just like the
written word will never be perfect
because it never can be perfect I'm
gonna get a little heavy here but Thomas
Jefferson said that the price of
democracy is eternal vigilance and I
think that applies equally to our system
of justice what I learned in this book
was that the most important thing about
any system of government is its ability
to expose itself to sunlight to let
people like me journalists in to see
what's going on and to the extent that
it does that
I think it is healthy and I think it's
the best system we can devise as human
beings the book served as an odd mirror
for people's preconceptions and it went
to really kind of ridiculous extremes in
a way what happened last spring was
ralph nader's organization called up and
they wanted a hundred copies of the book
because they were deeply engaged that
that at that point in trying to stem the
tide of tort reform and they thought
that this book had an important message
that the US Senators should read
I have utterly no confidence in the fact
that a hundred copies of the book given
one given to each senator that the
senator is ever going to read it but but
Nader thought that the message in quotes
was important and he wanted to hand it
out at the very same time that Nader
called I think it was not the same time
but two weeks later Rush Limbaugh I
heard had spent ten minutes on his radio
show talking about the book
I didn't hear actually hear Rush
Limbaugh in fact I've never heard Rush
Limbaugh but somebody sent me a
transcript of what he said and he said I
quote I got totally it's I got totally
captivated by the book it's one of the
best books about how the legal system
works that I've ever run across
regardless of which side you're on
now how Rush Limbaugh and Ralph Nader
can both adopt this the message of this
book is quite beyond me I should add
parenthetically that Limbaugh went on to
say it's a little ambiguous but he said
now I warn you some of you won't like it
because it's about a group of
Massachusetts families who sue
industrial giants for polluting the
water and making their kids sick
now I admit that there's a little
ambiguity in there but I think knowing
Rush Limbaugh where it probably comes
down
I am personally about as far removed on
the political spectrum from Rush
Limbaugh as you can be but let's face it
he's got a radio audience of eight
million people and if he wants to extol
the virtues of my book and perfectly
happy to have them do so one of the
things that makes me the happiest of all
though is that I am friends of a sort
I'm friendly with nearly everyone that I
wrote about this case was a very
bitterly fought case there was a lot of
bad blood between the lawyers and a lot
of personal animosity as it happened
though I genuinely liked just about
everyone not everyone but just about
everyone that I wrote about they
genuinely hated each other though and so
I was worried about how the book was
going to be received by them one thing
happened when I began this book tour for
the for the hardcover last fall I went
into Barnes & Noble down there the legal
area of Boston to sign some books
because I'd been asked to about by my
publisher and I got into Barnes & Noble
and went back to the information desk
and I saw this man standing there bill
Cheeseman he was the lead lawyer for WR
grace in this case and I wrote quite a
bit about him not all of it flattering
by any means and he had next to him 22
copies of this book stacked up buying
them he was going to give him out to
friends and family when he saw me he
said I hide the author in Bennett said
he was wondering how he's going to get
him back to the office and I could carry
him for
so I did after seeing Cheeseman I went
up to see Jerry Fisher I had an
appointment with him
Jerry basher the chairman of the
litigation department at Halen door and
he was the arch he was the Nemesis of
Quitman of the main character the lawyer
who represented the families throughout
the case
Jerry faster told me that I'd gotten a
few things wrong he actually excoriated
me for about 20 minutes first he said
his eyeglasses aren't thick as I'd said
therefore it was pretty extraordinary I
actually I think it actually thought he
was kidding but his demeanor was not one
of the guy who was kidding and then he
said that he never took leftovers from
the firm's weekly luncheon buffet and
plastic garbage bag his ID said and he
said to me I always use paper plates he
told me that his daughter Mimi thought
that I had completely failed to capture
his warm and fuzzy side and then after
taking me to task for that for about 20
minutes he said but the best thing is
we're still friend and he invited me out
to dinner my feeling throughout this was
that I can write a better story if I can
see the world through the eyes of the
characters that I write about in to the
extent that they do that I try
faithfully to represent their point of
view one other thing that Patra said to
me was he said a lot of other things
actually but one thing he said was that
he thought I was too hard on judge
Skinner he didn't say that I'd gotten
anything wrong about Skinner just that I
was too hard on him in some ways I
regret that I think most people who read
the book come out of it feeling that
Skinner was the villain I certainly I
would have liked to understand why
Skinner did what he did I think I know
but the judge wouldn't talk to me he
wouldn't let me see the world through
his eyes I especially would have liked
to see jan schlichtmann through the
judges eyes it's a wonderful narrative
device for a reader to see for a writer
have the reader see a character through
the eyes of another person and Rickman
could be maddening he was abrasive and
he was aggressive and he was arrogant
and I had no doubt that the judge was
infuriated with more time more occasions
than one and I would have loved to hear
the judge talk about that Judge never
did and maybe that's because he he
didn't want to but more probably it's
because he couldn't I think he felt an
ethical constraint having been the judge
in this case that he could not comment
on the lawyers in the end I'm gonna take
questions in a minute let me just finish
by saying that I I began this book with
two aims and the first thing really was
to entertain people and then to inform
people I can't pretend to stand before
you or any group of people especially
lawyers as an expert critic of the legal
system but I did look at this one case
in great depth I took about a fifth of
my life looking at it and in great depth
and I think that I hope that I've shed
some light on how the process works the
process of our legal system in this one
instance and then the and in that
process I hope that the I managed to
engage readers and entertain them
because that was I think my first
calling thank you all very much for
coming
any questions yeah you know John when I
hear you talk about the slow process and
the the difficulties you had and the
writing blocks I remember how you were
when you were an editor at The Advocate
and I was working for you where
everything seemed to just pour out of
you very quickly you were you always had
your stuff ready on time you always are
encouraging us to get stuff in early I'm
just wondering when you switch to the
long form what changed I think that was
a great illusion I never had things on
time I didn't have to write many stories
being the editor of The Advocate and
that's one reason why to be frank I
didn't much like being the editor The
Advocate
I wanted to write I think the longer
form is much more complicated Okrent
told me I've been writing these long
stories for New England Monthly and they
were getting to 12 or 15 thousand words
and I thought that was pretty long I
mean I'd accumulate a huge you know
amass a huge amount of research on these
things and I thought you know I'm not
that far from a book Okrent old mate
you're a long ways from a book the
threads that you have to weave and a
narrative are a much more complicated
fact is in a story of 15,000 words you
literally can hold all the parts in your
head you can understand the proportion
in the pace of it in a book length thing
you know maybe you can but I don't think
so I couldn't at least not in this one
yeah could you suggest about how many
hours a day during those eight years
you've spent writing the book and by
writing I include such things as lying
on the couch I would say probably it's
really hard to judge an awful lot you
know I mean it occupies your whole life
I was really completely self-absorbed
with so you know when I ate dinner I'd
be thinking about the book when my wife
came home I'd talked to her about the
book it really was a full-time
occupation in fact they didn't do
anything else I taught at Smith and that
was turned out to be I think a mistake
because
it that occupied a lot of time I I think
I would have been done maybe a couple
months earlier if I hadn't done that
yeah two questions first
Lichtman gave you an awful lot of time
did he ask for anything in return like
money and second do you have any plans
to publish your journal I can't answer
the second very quickly no it really
isn't that interesting it's really this
long lament it's I wrote in it when I
couldn't write the other stuff though
it's it's pretty pretty boring Rickman
asked for nothing and my condition going
into this was that he'd not be able to
read the manuscript there was nothing
there for him he gets a story told I'm
always amazed when people agree to to
let me be around and be a fly on the
wall you and he said at one point that
he had nothing - in fact he said it at
the very beginning he had nothing to
hide let me tell you a little bit about
how this came about how I got it
involved in this charlie nut for those
of you who read the book you'll
recognize some of these characters
Charlie Ness and Harvard Law Professor
had been seduced into the case by jan
schlichtmann in puerto rico Nessen got
very excited about it and Nessen talked
to a friend of his I think they were
playing poker and Charlie was was
talking about this case and what a great
great thing it was how it was gonna ring
the alarm in the corporate boardrooms of
America and Roger Hoffman a friend of
Charlie's who's also a friend of Tracy
Kidder said maybe Tracy would be
interested in writing about this I got
in Tracy's the one who got me involved
in the book and that's why he said he
would see me through it or else so
Charlie called Tracy Tracy said he
really wasn't interested his father's a
Wall Street lawyer and I don't think he
has any interest in writing about
lawyers and he suggested me because he
knew I was looking looking for for a
book so I went in and I met with Nessun
and then I met with Rickman sitting at
that conference table that I described
in the book eight lawyers around me I
was working for New England Monthly
I was either gonna do a story or a book
I had no idea whether it really be a
book in my condition was complete access
and I had nothing to lose you know a
footman said no I truly wasn't that
interested in writing about this case at
that point I had no burning desire to do
that
the only thing that mattered to me was
the access I would not I guarantee you
have written about this hedge Lichtman
not giving me that access and they asked
for several things in return one was
read the manuscript before publication I
said no can't do that
and I felt perfectly comfortable saying
no everything they wanted because I had
nothing to lose I had nothing invested
Strickland got no money out of the book
he did get some money out of Hollywood
Hollywood had to purchase his rights in
order I guess they felt they had to in
order to make the movie so he got some
money there and some of the other
characters may have to for all I know